اخبرني احد الاشخاص يعني قريب من احد
الوزراء
بعد ان اخبرني الرئيس سالني قال لي في
مسؤولين بدو يجوني شنو يعني شنو القصه فمن
سالتها قال لي كل اسبوع يجون اثنين
بعضهم يعني مؤدب
يعني ما يحكوا ما يتكلم بس والبعض الاخر
يجي بطريقه متشفين وحدد لي الاسماء اللي
افتهمته فيه ما بعد من مقرب من احد
الوزراء
اجتمع بيهم
اياد علاوي على حسب ما نقل اليه وطلب منا
الوزراء انه الذهاب الى
الرئيس صدام حسين
والتشفي فيه فاحد كل الوزراء وافقوا الا
احد الوزراء وهو من مشيخه من مشايخ الجنوب
ومن عشيره وقبيله معروفه ومحترمه رفض رفض
لا اسميه وزير الدفاع الاسم الشعلان
ما ذكر بالضبط
وقال
رئيس الوزراء انا ذاك اياد علاوي انه هذا
مو من يعني من اصول العرب ولا الرئيس خلص
يعني راح ابرز الاسماء اللي زارته او
استفزته برهم صالح وقال لك انه استفزوا
شخصيا قال لا ما قال استفزي بس قال ما كان
يعني
وضعه مو طبيعي يعني ما كان لا محب ولا
كاره بس كان يسال يعني كثير سؤال وزاره
وزير السياحه ما اتذكر شو اسمه
وزير السياحه السابق اذا راى باختيار امين
كمان باختيار امين
قال كان مؤدب وسالني عندك مكان تزرع بيه
يعني حوض كان منطينه يزرع بيه وزارني
[موسيقى]
فلاح النقيب
ايضا تحدثنا معه في هذا البرنامج عن
زيارته هو تحدث عن زيارته له
زياره جماعيه مع السفير بوليبريمر
والجيران القوات الامريكيه اعتقد كان موفق
الرباعي
واحمد شلبي احمد شلبي نعم
لكانت تستفزه هذه الزيارات
استفزهم وفق الرباعيه اثناء الزياره
بماذا استفز يعني يقول كان يعني بعيد عني
وقف وكان يعني يتكلم بذاع الفاظ نابيه
يقول حتى القنا درس يقول مسكون الامريكان
وابعدوا عني